how's it going brahs Wow
oh my god today I have the best games
ever for you bros I am NOT just saying
that it is for real one of you bros
suggested it so if it's bad it's your
phone but it looks [ __ ] amazing let's
start with stomach hurt best title I
ever heard game of the year let the yolk
hit the frisbee game is over fart and
pain what the [ __ ]
charging it and I farted and uh um I
think that was a video game I charge my
farts oh okay I get it I have to duck
but I can't fart genius oh [ __ ] I let it
out oh yeah these games man they just
become better and better
oh these are slow Oh God
Oh God ah [ __ ] ah me every time I fart
could this be game of the year could
this be game of the century yes yes yes
the answer is yes yes yes
gotta get those ABS Oh muscle on the sea
what a great name wow what a great name
I love it I love the graphics by the way
finger is okay to use what is this
finger it's okay to use what this okay
that's good
use about six it is good to have a
tatata how high were they when they made
this just tap the screen alright
gotta go fast I gotta go fast
dammit I'm not Jesus no matter how many
apps I have I can never be Jesus oh oh
if I use many fingers Wow Oh what
happened
damn it yay I'm Sanok I'm live version
of Sanok
I can just go forever the [ __ ] is the
point two fingers ah ah three four five
six fingers gotta go fast gotta go fast
you to service it baby
oh no I'm sinking no no no I'm sinking
just got a leg
braaap braap video games video games
video is it getting harder oh it is oh
no no no no no no no ah ah ah it crashed
uh favorite game ever ten out of ten
next up we have a dissolve somebody by
the same developer by the way great
great job ah summer powerful ski jumping
dance dead gains stood a powerful ski
jumping summer dance they aim a point in
the center of the frame on the screen
swipe the more points become green close
to center then speed will accelerate you
do not have to do anything during the
jump please pray I will pray to the
Swedish Lords Oh God look at that ass
look at my ass oh man that's add some
fresh SS SS / Svein si
oh god oh god I'm aiming brah Wow how
the hell am I gonna okay the framerate
is so good oh man this looks so good
chef super hard mushroom and muscle what
the [ __ ]
this is flappy bird isn't it what the
[ __ ]
oh my god it's really wonderful game
makes you question life this game
doesn't it makes you question what the
[ __ ] you're doing with it ah Sh oh God
oh we made it oh my god oh my god I'm
gonna get a high score [ __ ] ah ah ah ah
if only I could travel a little slower
that would be cool I mean look at that
ass can you can you seriously look at
that as and say this is not a good game
anyway last one pitcher will throw a
ball all three colors let's backstroke
the ball
okay sure why not yellow purple purple
blue [ __ ] [ __ ] ah ah ah ah blue hello
hello hello hello purple yellow yellow
blue yellow yellow
yellow hello yeah
there you go there's a couple three
games for you I hope you boys enjoy this
video I had a lot of fun playing so
[ __ ] thank you much for watching as
always stay awesome bros haha I kept
telling him so many times
Jesus Christ is out of control he's
trying to become a helicopter oh my god
he's flying our Lord and Savior goat
take us to Heaven's